as an early mist lifted gently off the
tine
it was replaced for many people along
this great river
with a fog of rules the restrictions
confusing people
willing to comply but uncertain
best mates colin and john trying to work
it all out
the way that the the rules and
regulations have been brought out
in a piecemeal way almost on a daily
basis
and it's very very difficult to keep up
with it
many here will comply but have their
suspicions
there is i suppose a kind of general
acceptance of the new
restrictions here but also a strong
feeling that they're being
targeted as some sort of social
experiment with coronavirus
i'm off on a journey of about 150 miles
across
the north of england and i'll be ending
up in lancashire
a county facing very similar
restrictions
hi good morning
from the northeast we travel across
yorkshire heading west across a region
of this country
where millions are living under renewed
limitations
well we just pulled over because while
we've been on the road
uh travelling through yorkshire we've
just noticed a whole new set of lockdown
rules announced
in west yorkshire so we're going to ask
people here what they think about it
at the peace hall in halifax an 18th
century courtyard
where cloth was traded and where it is
now cafes and restaurants
there is real concern among bar owners
like mark richardson
hand on heart i think there'll be a few
that
particularly if there was another lock
down probably won't come back from it
um people like to go out and have a beer
and socialize go to live music
and i know that's taken a real hit and
among the families here
growing frustration it's quite annoying
in a way because like i said you can mix
with certain people you can
you can go to the pub and sit with
people but then you can't see other
certain
family members friends um so yeah it's
just
confusing and so across into lancashire
we drove
to the old industrial towns of the north
west
in akrington the new local lockdown
surprises few
but worries many this bar owner says
it's not worth staying open
it wouldn't be viable for us to stay
open because we've not got enough
seating area
inside it's not just a nightmare for
myself i have staff members as well so
obviously my staff
the staff are going to lose out as well
you know it's the stability of obviously
their wage coming in every week
this virus continues to threaten the
lives of some
and hamper the lives of many millions
more